I would just want to update you now
we've had the latest data from the
Department of Health on the latest
number of coronavirus cases we had told
you earlier that that new number was a
hundred and sixty-nine with five new
cases confirmed in Scotland we now
understand from the Department of Health
that that number for the UK in total has
gone up to 206 when our correspondent
under Brady is still with us here in the
studio as a big jump this information
has literally just been published by the
Department of Health and if we take a
look at it so yesterday UK wide the
figure last night stood at 164 and as of
7:00 a.m. this morning they're telling
us that the number now stands at 206 so
that's an increase of 42 and we know
that five of those cases new cases are
in Scotland and just looking at it we're
now up to 206 or just going through the
data the majority of the cases again are
in the Greater London area and the
southeast and we're now looking at 206
cases UK wide positive tests now they
have tested 21,000 460 people across the
UK and 21,000 254 have confirmed
negative so 206 people are positive with
the virus in the UK and of course two
people have died from Colvard 19 in the
past 48 hours they're a man and a woman
the lady was in her 70s the man was in
his 80s the she was in the Royal
Berkshire Hospital in Redding he was at
a hospital in Milton Keynes they both
had underlying health conditions so it
is a significant rise up 42 cases in 24
hours and we are expecting to hear from
the government aren't we on Monday about
possible new measures concerning in
particular the elderly yes so right now
we're still in the containment phase of
the outbreak there are four phases three
key ones and alongside all of those
research is ongoing so we have
containment delay mitigation and
research so the research is constantly
ongoing into this fight
we're still in the containment phrase
and the government are confident that it
is being contained as well as possible
the delay phase would be moving to
measures like restricting movement of
the elderly people going to sporting
gatherings and what-have-you there will
be meetings on Monday obviously the
Prime Minister the chief medical officer
the chief scientific adviser they are
talking all the time about this so a
month is a significant day and the whole
issue of delaying the spread of the
virus is to basically give hospitals
uk-wide the chance to get out of winter
to get away from January February and
March and the winter flu bugs and all
the pressure on the systems that they
have in those winter months so to push
the peak of the virus which we have not
yet seen towards the summer so that they
can basically just manage their
resources as well as they possibly can
but that's a significant jump 42 new
cases in the space of 24
you